It's 2026. The avalanche of apostasy is
accelerating. The DA bros are panicking.
And when they panic, they get even
stupider. They get sloppier. They get
more aggressive. They get more violent.
They lash out in all directions. Earlier
this month, Tik Tok jihadis doxed my
entire family. They posted my home
address. They posted my wife's phone
number and started calling her in the
middle of the night when I was out of
town. They posted the address and phone
number of a place she volunteers at.
They're saying they're going to Charlie
kirk me. They keep saying they're going
to show up at my door, but they're also
saying they're going to kill me at
Debatecon, which is two days away. So,
they can't make up their minds. They've
been posting videos with pictures of my
wife with gunshot noises, pictures of my
kids. My days are supposedly numbered
because the pop pop is coming when I'm
in Houston this weekend. Did he wood?
Let's see how much longer you going to
last.
Time's running out. Houston, huh, papa?
This dumb dawa dork named Malik even
flashed some cash because there's
apparently a price on my head. Hey,
David Wood.
David Wood, I got something for David
Wood.
David Wood.
Those little Qurans you blasted, David,
that's that's on your head now. That's
on your head now.
Shout out my boy J Prince out in
Houston, man.
>> No violence yet, even though they know
exactly where I am. Instead, they've
been trying to annoy me. Jihadis just
aren't what they used to be. They've
been doing things like calling animal
control over and over again to come
check on our dog. We're renting this
house. I've never met the owner, but
they tracked him down and they've been
calling and harassing him. Lots of weird
stupid stuff like that. And this is in
addition to going after God logic and
his wife, doxing inspiring philosophy,
doxing Chris Claus, Thaddius, Drake, and
so on. The Tik Tok jihadis are throwing
a pretty epic tantrum to start off the
new year. Now, my position is that even
if I were capable of backing down from
these walking clown emojis, I still
wouldn't back down from threats and
doxing because the moment I back down
from threats and doxing, they'll think
they have some great new way of making
Christians submit and they'll just start
doing it to Christians everywhere. So, I
will stand my ground to the death so
this doesn't become their standard way
of controlling people. But I have to go
beyond not backing down because this has
to blow up in their faces. It has to end
in disaster for their religion. The
consequences of their actions have to be
traumatic for their entire community. So
that after this batch of Tik Tok jihadis
ends up humiliated and defeated, the
consequences will be so traumatic that
the Muslim community will police their
own. In other words, if someone comes
along next year and says, "Hey, I think
I'll start doxing Christians and
harassing their wives," the Muslim
community will scream, "You idiot. How
do you not know what happened the last
time someone tried this?" And it's even
more serious than doxing or threatening
people. Islam is absolutely obsessed
with controlling people outside the
religion by any means possible. In a
Muslim country, there will be laws
against criticizing Islam or preaching
the gospel. Even apart from these laws,
if you're a Christian or a Hindu or
something else and you simply annoy or
disrespect a Muslim, he'll start
screaming, "Help! Help! This person
insulted Muhammad," and a mob will form.
The goal is to keep non-Muslims in a
constant state of fear. That's in Muslim
countries, but even in non-Muslim
countries, they're constantly trying to
figure out ways to gain control. That's
why they're trying to get blasphemy laws
passed. That's why they want everything
halal certified. It's why they block
roads to pray. It's all about control.
And the moment they figure out a way to
take control, lots of people suffer
terribly. The most successful tools of
Islam in the West have been claiming
victim status and crying about
Islamophobia.
Think about what happened the moment
they realized they could control
Westerners by pretending to be victims
and calling anyone who questions them
Islamophobes.
Tens of thousands of young British girls
were horribly abused by Muslim men who
figured out how to control police,
social workers, the courts, and so on.
You can't give them an inch ever or lots
of people will suffer because you gave
them a lever. And so right now they're
trying doxing and harassing people with
calls and threats and so on to see what
works.
If anything works, it's going to be
their new favorite tactic. Sadly for
them, they're trying this stuff on me
and they can saw my head off. I'm not
backing down. On the contrary, I
responded to their doxing and harassing
and threats by feeding my dog bacon
wrapped Quran pages
>> and by putting these clowns on trial for
their actions and pronouncing judgment
on the Quran.
>> Judge Hammer Time
has declared that court is in session.
Look upon the consequences of your bad
decisions.
Gaze upon
the shredding of the Quran that you have
caused.
And with episode one of Kuran Demolition
Ranch, if you stalk women, harass women,
dox women, and threaten women, your
favorite verses are going to be
plastered on a 4x8 board. Your fake
prophet is going to be painted in pig's
blood. Your pagan book is going to be
nailed to a platter. And the whole mess
will be shot, chainsawed, and burned
right here at the Kuran Demolition
Ranch. And with a short tribute to
Salwan Mika, who was brutally murdered
one year ago today for demonstrating his
contempt for the Quran, we put together
a nice fire pit full of Qurans. And I
took some 151 proof rum and did this.
Tomorrow is International Zut
Remembrance Day, January 30th. 130. Get
it? One Muhammad and 30 men of Zut.
We've got a special video for that. One
white Quran surrounded by 30 black
Qurans. The white Quran gets some holes
in it. You get the picture.
>> Look at him. The poor fake prophet is
all tuckered out.
But the men of Alz look happy.
And that will be followed by our top 100
ways to zoot the Quran compilation of
videos provided by viewers who like me
want to teach the da bros a lesson for
doxing people. And this is all phase one
of teaching these guys to never ever do
this again. But we're doing all of this.
And they're promising to kill me. And
they're posting videos with pictures of
my wife with gunshot sounds. And they're
posting pictures of my kids. And they've
all got my home address. They know
exactly where we are. Now, no one thinks
that Malik, a little ring leader of the
Tik Tok jihadis, is going to do anything
himself. He's a whiny little coward, but
he's trying to instigate and incite
other Muslims to come murder me and
maybe my wife. And there are definitely
some Muslims out there who would be
happy to do it. I keep running my mouth
anyway because antisocial personality
disorder makes dangerous situations fun
and because I just think I'll win.
Unless they come with an army, I'll win
when they come through the door. One
jihadi, two jihadis, three jihadis, four
jihadis, five jihadis. They'll lose that
one. They'll just lose. I travel two or
three times per month for speaking or
debates, so I figured I could hire
security for when I'm gone. Turns out
professional security guards are really
expensive, which is weird. I grew up in
a trailer park in West Virginia, and I
know for a fact that to this day, I
could walk up to just about any dude in
that trailer park and say, "Here's 50
bucks and a six-ack of cores. Grab your
shotgun and stay on my couch until I get
back and it would be the safest place in
the world. Things are different here.
These jokers want thousands of dollars.
I guess it's because they're putting
their lives at risk. So, I was going to
have to figure out what do I do when I'm
traveling. But then I spotted another
problem. I headed back to the gym
earlier this month. Early last year, I
was getting pretty shredded. Then at the
beginning of April, I tore something in
the back of my shoulder. So, I stopped
going to the gym to let it heal. Never
got back to the gym all year. Gained
like 25 lbs or so. It made sense for the
new year to get back to the gym. So, I'm
in the gym a couple of weeks ago. And
then I think,
what if they storm through the door now
while I'm right down the street? The
only people at home are a nurse, my
special needs son, Paley, our youngest
son who's seven, and my wife. That
wouldn't go well. See, when we think
about what other people are going to do,
we assume that they have some level of
common sense. So, if jihadis decide to
kill me in my house, we assume they're
going to do it while I'm there. The
problem with that assumption is that
sometimes we're dealing with complete
morons. I can't assume they'll storm the
house while I'm there. They may be total
idiots. And different jihadis would do
different things. There are jihadis who
would only want to kill me and not
target women or children. and there are
jihadis who would massacre everyone. So
I concluded that we do need to move to a
different location so my family isn't in
danger. Problem is we're renting this
house and I'm under lease for most of
the year. If I move I'll be paying two
rents for a while and I suspect they'll
eventually find us again. They won't be
doxing anymore after the valuable life
lesson we're teaching them now. But as
far as finding out where I am and just
killing me, that seems like something
that could happen. I think it takes a
while, maybe a couple of years after you
move to be able to find you through
these websites they go to. I might just
have to get used to moving every couple
of years. Or if one of you out there is
rich and you want to buy a house and you
own it and your name is on it and I just
pay you rent, but my name is never on
anything that anyone can look up ever,
that would solve some problems. But if I
have to move every 2 or 3 years to keep
my family safe, that's what I'll do.
Still not sure what to do security-wise.
I know I can get cameras and a service
that monitors the cameras and calls
police. If there's a breakin, that makes
sense. If people are breaking in to
steal things, I'm not sure how much it
would help with jihadis. Seems like if
jihadis bust through the door, either
I'm going to win pretty quickly or
they're going to massacre everyone
quickly. But either way, seems like it's
going to be over before police arrive.
Maybe cameras help with identifying them
later. I don't know. Not sure what I
want to do as far as security.
Might want to have a panic room built so
my wife and anyone else can head there
while I'm busy wrecking jihadis. Not
sure about those details yet, but I do
need to move my family somewhere else
while I convince the DA Bros that doxing
people and stalking and harassing and
threatening women and targeting people's
families will always, always, always
lead to mass desecration of their pagan
book. and that since they're the ones
who are instigating this treatment of
their pagan book, they're the ones who
are responsible for people around the
world disrespecting and degrading their
book and their religion. Again, even if
they don't care much about their book,
some of their fellow Muslims do. And the
Muslims who care about their book will
make the ones who don't care about their
book stop what they're doing. Matter of
time, watch what happens. Some people
got to learn the hard way, but they will
learn. We've been gearing up for other
things. Major changes and a huge
ministry expansion for the past several
months. Giant DOC get here tonight. You
should see them in person for the first
time ever tomorrow. But since we've been
gearing up for other things, I am not in
a good position to be moving and paying
rent on two houses right now. when the
Tik Tok jihadis started harassing the
owner. I was actually hoping he would
kick us out so that I wouldn't have this
problem, but he didn't. Hasn't said a
word. So, if you'd like to chip in to
help cover the move and the extra rent
and whatever security upgrades we decide
on, there's a link to a gives go in the
description. Just so you know, this is
going to be a messy year for everyone.
Again, when they go into panic mode,
they lash out. It's kind of like the
instinct of a wounded animal. But this
is going to be the worst year for Da
ever. Just look at how January is going
for them and imagine what the rest of
the year is going to be like. Chip in if
you can. I'll start looking for a
different place. I'll get my family
moved to a different spot and we'll keep
cooking. If you're in the Houston area,
I hope to see you at Debatecon. And if
you're a jihadi planning to slaughter me
in the name of Allah,
better hurry up and come at me, bro,
because I won't be here for long.
You
just backfire on me. You
just back on [music] me. This is a power
of religion. There's a reason to it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.